dozens of candles can be lit from a
single candle
and its life will not get any shorter
happiness
doesn't diminish when you share it
thinking that someone else can make you
happy or unhappy
is ridiculous
a disciplined mind
brings happiness
do not envy other people's good
qualities
but
instill them in yourself
through admiration
conquer anger with non-anger
conquer badness with goodness
conquer meanness with generosity
conquer dishonesty with truth
those who cling to perceptions and views
wander the world offending people
drop by drop
is the water pot filled
likewise
the wise man
gathering it little by little
fills himself
with good
let none find fault with others
let none see the omissions and
commissions of others
but let one see one's own acts
done and undone
should a person do good
let him do it again and again
let him find pleasure therein
for blissful
is the accumulation of good
should you find a wise critic to point
out your faults
follow him as you would a guide to
hidden treasure
should a seeker not find a companion who
is better or equal
let them resolutely pursue a solitary
course
in whom
there is no sympathy for living beings
know him
as an outcast
hatred
is never appeased by hatred in this
world
by non-hatred alone
is hatred appeased
this
is an eternal law
all that we are
is the result of our thoughts
all conditioned things
are impermanent
when one sees this with wisdom
one turns away from suffering
ardently do today
what must be done
who knows
tomorrow
death comes
the world is afflicted by death and
decay
but the wise do not grieve
having realized the nature of the world
to support mother and father
to cherish wife and children
and to be engaged in peaceful occupation
this is the greatest blessing
just
as the great ocean has one taste
the taste of salt
so also this teaching and discipline
has one taste
the taste of liberation
it is in the nature of things that joy
arises in a person
free from remorse
all experiences
are preceded by mind
having mind as their master
created by mind
understanding is the heartwood of
well-spoken words
just as a solid rock is not shaken by
the storm
even so the wise are not affected by
praise or blame
there is no fear of death
for one who is not filled with desires
whatever is not yours
let go of it
you're letting go of it will be for your
long-term happiness
and benefit
any increased attachment to everything
earthly
is suffering
if you knew what i know about the power
of giving
you would not let a single meal pass
without sharing it in some way
death
never takes a wise man by surprise
if he is always ready to go
your own self is your master
who else could be
with yourself well controlled
you gain a master very hard to find
do not dwell in the past
do not dream of the future
concentrate the mind on the present
moment
be truthful
do not yield to anger
give freely even if you have but little
the gods will bless you
the whole secret of existence
is to have no fear
never fear what will become of you
depend on no one
only the moment you reject all help
are you freed
property
is not things but thoughts
you can have things
and still not be the owner
not life and not wealth
and not power make a slave out of a
person
but only his attachment to life
wealth
and power
do not answer evil for evil
otherwise there will be no end to evil
in response to an offense
kiss your enemy
and he will become much more painful
it matters not how a man dies
but how he lives
the act of dying is not of importance
it lasts so short a
time there are many teachings in the
world
but no teachings will help one who has
shackled himself
happiness is not a fortunate combination
of external circumstances
it is just the state of your mind
he
can do anything
who thinks that he can do anything
our death is not an end if we can live
on in our children
and the younger generation
for they are us
our bodies are only wilted leaves
on the tree of life
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
don't miss out on a chance to see the
next video subscribe